president Kofi Fei our beloved troll in
chief has reportedly requested a
military parade down Pennsylvania Avenue
for either Memorial Day or Independence
Day or Veterans Day the left and
anti-trump Republicans historically
ignorant frequently wrong but never in
doubt insists that honoring our military
is unprecedented and will destroy the
Republic we will analyze the illustrious
history of military parades in the
United States and how Trump should stage
it then Elisha Kraus and Ariel Davidson
joined to discuss breaking news last
night Fox News released a shocking
report on texts between FBI agents Peter
struck and Lisa page showing that James
Comey former FBI director ordered the
two agents to prepare an update on
ongoing investigations because quote
POTUS wants to know everything we're
doing which shows that Barack Obama was
lying through his teeth
surprise surprise when he said on
national television that he did not
interfere with the Attorney General or
FBI directors about pending
investigations then variations on a
theme trey Gowdy has all but admitted
that the source of information passed to
Hillary's State Department to be passed
to dossier Arthur Christopher Steele to
be passed to Barack Obama's FBI was none
other than Clinton hatchet man Sidney
Blumenthal meaning that the entire
Russia collusion investigation circus
may have likely been a charade funded
orchestrated and executed by Clinton
cronies to undermine Trump's campaign
shocking isn't it and in the most
important news Canada's Prime Minister
Ken doll Justin Trudeau wants to change
the word mankind to people kind because
he's illiterate I'm Michel Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
that's a lot that's a lot to get to
there is so much and this is very
important because everybody is so dead
certain they're making these great
historical claims and they don't really
know anything about what they're talking
about
so we'll clear that up a little bit but
first look you know youyou saw I
interviewed yesterday myself from the
future mother the 200th episode Michael
and things don't look very good the
trouble here of course is we've
broadcast from the ben shapiro broom
closet that's very nice I they keep
promising they're gonna send me a
paycheck at some point but you know well
it won't see what that happens the one
real nice benefit though is sometimes we
get wonderful sponsors who will feed me
and make sure that I don't become
emaciated and that and they can feed you
too this is great we're very happy to
welcome a new sponsor today to help keep
the lights on maybe a day or two longer
blue apron blue apron is the leading
meal kit delivery service in the US and
while many people know what they do you
very often they don't know about the
types of meals that you can eat when you
cook with blue apron so you think well
who knows that some meals that come it's
probably very similar it's all the same
stuff no way you get strip steaks with
potatoes spicy maple collard greens a
steakhouse inspired favorite with a
delicious twist chili infused maple
syrup with incredible ingredients and
chef designed recipes blue apron lets
you see what the power of food can do i
and by the way they're really easy to
prepare if you're like me you just ask
sweet little Alisa to prepare it and
then it comes out very delicious and
good and and you can you can have that
power to sweet little Alisa is not
included though with your blue apron
subscription so what do you get you at
convenience and variety blue apron
delivers fresh pre proportioned
proportion ingredients and step-by-step
recipes right to your door that can be
cooked in under 45 minutes the menu
changes every single week based on
what's in season and is designed by blue
aprons in-house culinary team you are
not going to see these recipes repeated
you are signing up for a culinary
experience that will keep changing and
keep growing it's got a lot of
flexibility blue apron offers 12 new
recipes each week customers can pick two
three or four recipes based on what fits
their schedule obviously you got to go
for the
that's that's kind of what I recommend
you get the four maybe you have one at a
time maybe up two at a time maybe you
have three I don't know it depends what
kind of night it is high quality food
blue apron sends only non GMO
ingredients went and meat with no added
hormones if I were left to my own
druthers I'd probably just eat hormones
I probably just be in like the gutter
eating hormones out of the garbage
luckily blue apron clear set up you get
some healthier food and not all of that
artificial stuff that's probably not
very good for you it this is really good
stuff all of my friends are using it it
is so good a sweet little ELISA it has
already planned out what the menus are
going to look like on it because if I
turn on the stove I think that probably
all event or Boulevard will explode
the call to action here is that you need
to go to blue apron dot-com / Co FFA do
not just hear about these wonderful
recipes do not just hear oh that sounds
nice well Michael can enjoy good food
don't do it you have an opportunity here
if you had a blue apron come / co' FFA
Michael Knowles show listeners will get
$30 off your first order check it out
check out this week's menu get $30 off
I'm giving you free food don't say I
never did anything for you
blue apron dot-com / cough FA what is it
Marshall
/ cough FA blue apron a better way to
cook alright the president is destroying
the country did you know that he's
destroying the country again we're all
gonna die
and I know you already died from tax
reform and deregulation and moving our
embassy and Israel to the capital of
Israel and appointing an originalist to
the Supreme Court and reinstituting the
Mexico City policy and pulling out of
the Paris climate Accord you zombie you
undead drone wandering through the world
suffering death after death but
relentlessly existing the new mainstream
media hysteria is that President Trump
wants to have a military parade I wish I
had pearls on like a clutch and grits so
horrible here is Rear Admiral John Kirby
who was the State Department spokesman
under Barack Obama explaining why he
hates the parade idea so Admiral Kirby
what do you think of the idea of a
military parade in Washington I don't
like it al so not not at all this is not
about showcasing our millet
this is about the president showing off
this is all about his ego and that's
just an inappropriate use of military
time and talent and resources and the
week the second thing is this is beneath
us as a nation we are the most powerful
military on earth we're very proud of
that and rightly so we don't need to be
parade in our military hardware down
Pennsylvania Avenue to to show that to
anybody and thirdly I think it's just a
waste of resources it will cost millions
of dollars that's money that can be put
to other better uses operations training
not to mention just even just taking
care of our people spouse education
programs that kind of thing so I think
this is just a it's a it's a
tremendously bad idea the trouble with a
curt of this analysis kirby comes out he
says this isn't what we do in america
it's okay we like the military but we
don't parade our our troops down the
streets we don't need to show other
people our tanks or our missiles it's
unamerican it's what people do in other
countries and dictatorships and and the
military hates it in the country hates
it and we've never seen it before and
it's awful the trouble with that
analysis and I've heard this repeated ad
nauseam all morning is that it isn't
true people I understand people say if
it reminds me of Soviet Russia oh it
reminds me of the North Korea okay yes
it were places have military parades -
the United States has regularly paraded
soldiers and tanks and missiles through
the streets of the capital and other
cities for over 150 years just a quick
history of these after the Civil War
President Andrew Johnson held a military
parade of a hundred 45,000 Union
soldiers parading down Pennsylvania
Avenue the procession known as the grand
review of the armies took place over two
days May 23rd and 24th three years and
six days before the first Memorial Day
was celebrated after World War one the
u.s. held military parades in New York
DC countless other cities to greet
doughboys as they returned from the
battlefield that's what that's what
sweet little ISA calls me by the way is
a Doughboy I don't think it's for the
same reason General Black Jack Pershing
led at the parade of thousands of
soldiers through the streets of New York
on September 10th 1919 and then he led
another parade of thousands of soldiers
through the streets of DC about a week
later we also had military parades in
1942 and 1946 the 1942
parade in New York lasted for more than
11 hours it was attended by two million
people that parade even featured a
gigantic bust of Franklin Roosevelt of
the President they pulled a gigantic
head of FDR down the the street in the
1942 parade and and yet we are told to
have a little military parade in America
today would be awful it would be Trump
becoming a dictator as far as I can tell
the current preparations don't include a
gigantic Trump head on a float but who
knows things could change in 1946 a
military parade was held in New York to
celebrate the Allied victory in World
War two the 1946 parade saw some of the
largest self-propelled howitzers in the
entire army rolling down the streets of
New York tanks rolling down the streets
of New York in 1953 at President
Eisenhower's first inauguration another
event where we're commemorating a guy
where we're commemorating the
inauguration there were 73 bands 59
floats and lots of military assets
including an 85 ton atomic cannon that
could fire a shell 20 miles tanks as far
as the eye could see rolled through
Washington guess what happened four
years later and again this this wasn't
to celebrate a particular victim or this
wasn't to celebrate something else other
than this guy's inauguration and
Eisenhower his second inauguration
thousands of troops marched three miles
down Washington with countless tanks
rolling along side plus the 69 foot long
red stone which was the first ballistic
missile successfully fired by the United
States missiles tanks thousands and
thousands of troops all marching down
the road four years later so we had 53
57 now in 1961 at JFK's inauguration
dozens of missiles were paraded in front
of the world including the Nike Zeus
which was the first missile that could
intercept ballistic missiles so we're
being told now by the left and Trump
critics and former Obama administration
officials we we don't need to show our
military equipment off we would never do
that it would be such a step backward so
small-minded of the United States if we
ever showed off our military equipment
we've been doing it for well over
regularly we did 53 3761 we did and four
year intervals for a while and that's
not just missiles during the JFK parade
even huge Navy boats were towed down
Pennsylvania Avenue with Kennedy aboard
waving to the throngs on boats that
specifically resembled the one that he
himself commanded in World War two in
more recent history in 1991 President
George HW Bush held a massive military
parade in Washington here's the coverage
then good evening well already they are
saying tonight it was the biggest
military celebration in the nation's
capitol since World War two as
Washington today honored the US
servicemen and women who fought in the
Gulf War both those who returned and
those who died 200,000 enthusiastic
spectators watched a parade of troops in
their weapons all part of the national
victory celebration Eric enge Burton has
our report it was a day for saying thank
you to heroes the president choked back
tears several times as he spoke directly
to loved ones of those who died on the
wide boulevards just a few blocks from
the White House 8,000 Desert Storm
troops were moving out and once again it
was general Norman Schwarzkopf who set
the cadence leading the way as far as
the presidential box where he spent the
rest of the parade as cheerleader and
spotter for a clearly delighted George
Bush
so much military hardware was moving
that at times it appeared Washington was
under attack well here justice I thank
you and to celebrate our victory but to
say thank you to all the men and women
who serve in the armed forces now I
think that this is a wonderful occasion
but we don't want it to happen again
we don't wonderful and of course that's
the sentiment we don't want war we don't
want but we want to honor the the
service and the sacrifice of our troops
tanks rolling through Washington DC
we're now being told that the streets
would all crack if we if we drove tanks
down them we've done this plenty of
times and it's just fine it looked like
Washington was under attack but that's
what these parades look like so after
that were after the Persian Gulf War
Iraq part 1 tributes were held nearly
every day to welcome home troops though
the largest celebrations were held in
New York and DC yes there's plenty of
precedent for this don't get that out of
your mind
nevertheless many leftist commentators
still object Douglas Brinkley a
presidential historian and insufferable
lefty said on CNN quote I don't think
there's a lack of love and respect for
our armed forces in the United States
give me a break but we'll get to that
later what what are they going to do
stand there while Donald Trump waves at
them it smacks of something you see in a
totalitarian country unless there's a
genuine earnest reason to be doing it
now the historian Wilfred McClay
observed in 2006 that Douglas Brinkley
has failed to quote put forward a single
memorable idea a single original
analysis or a single lapidary phrase
likewise the author Bill Bryson has
called Brinkley a minor American
academic and sometime critic whose
powers of observation and generosity of
spirit would fit comfortably into a
proton and still leave room for an echo
absolutely right even the sentiment is
totally wrong and even on the historical
points he's making they're just not true
at the White House for its part also
rejects the notion that a military
parade is totalitarian saying that it
would be a celebration of the men and
women who give us freedom who protect
our freedom that's the opposite of a
totalitarian government they say and
that's true brinkley says we should only
have parades when there's a genuine
earnest reason to be doing it sure now
by the way this wasn't always the case
in
the century we had three back-to-back
four years four years four years that
were not being done earnestly to
celebrate some war victory or something
though clearly there was a strategic
purpose it was to frighten our enemies
it was to frighten the Soviet Union just
as today we have enemies that we could
reasonably frighten and show off our
bigger buttons that's exactly why though
that there has been a groundswell and
support in recent years for a military
parade at like the one we're talking
about to honor veterans of the wars in
Iraq and Afghanistan why shouldn't we
honor them the last military parade we
held in Washington was to honor the
veterans of the last major war we
concluded but the veterans of Iraq and
Afghanistan who served their country
admirably after the September 11th
terrorist attacks they've never had
their own parade they've never had that
moment that's why even Chuck Schumer has
called for this parade in 2014
Schumer held a press conference and I
know this is shocking because the most
dangerous place in the world as we all
know is not in the Middle East on the
fighting grounds or in the air or on the
sea it's the space between Chuck Schumer
in a television camera I digress Schumer
held a press conference on Broadway at
Bowling Green right by statues of George
Washington where Washington gave his
farewell to the Troops and he said with
the war in Afghanistan winding down now
is the time to keep with long-standing
American tradition and kick off a
campaign for the first New York City
welcome home parade for troops that
served in Iraq and Afghanistan for the
first that implies multiple parades that
he's suggesting he goes on with the
completion of the Afghanistan combat
mission expected at the end of this year
and with Iraq's official and far behind
us it's time for New York to stake its
claim and for the Department of Defense
to join in planning this welcome home
celebration then joining the chorus of
calls for a military parade to honor
those veterans came none other than New
York's Bolshevik Mayor Bill DeBlasio
even Bill DeBlasio said quote the brave
men and women who have selflessly served
our nation with courage and skill in
Iraq and Afghanistan deserve a
recognition for this sacrifice I stand
with Senator Schumer in his call for a
parade to honor our veteran heroes and
New York City would be proud to host
this important event I'm glad we all
agree I'm glad you agree Chuck and I'm
glad you
bill and I fully expect you to keep your
mouth shut well president Trump plans
the new one so what happened
why no parade there's a point here
there's no parade because the war in
Afghanistan was still basically in full
swing by that time 75% of US casualties
in Afghanistan had occurred under Barack
Obama's watch that was in 2015 2014-2015
Barack Obama who insisted on restarting
a war that we'd already won because he
had to balance out his vocal criticism
of the Iraq war which he recklessly
chose to lose because his opposition to
Iraq was central to his winning the
Democratic nomination over Hillary
Clinton the Defense Department under
Barack Obama filter would not look good
to host a parade for military veterans
until the war in Afghanistan was
completed the trouble is that our
current operations in Afghanistan have
increasingly become a stabilizing
mission what might be called a war of
empire so they're still fighting but the
fear of pulling US troops out is that
the country will then fall into disarray
again and provide a safe haven for
terrorists who have to go right back in
and we know is already doing that for
the years before September 11th which is
the reason we had to intervene in the
first place
so if that's the kind of war that we're
engaged in then there can be no clear
moment of victory no mission
accomplished banner it might look like
Korea you know we've had Korea and we've
had troops stationed in Korea to prevent
the outbreak of new violence for 61
years
Afghanistan is the longest war we have
ever engaged in 16 years and counting
number one on the list after that and
that's followed by the Moro rebellion
which is a word that absolutely no one
knows about it was one in which Muslim
tribes living in the southern
Philippines attacked US troops after the
US government had told them that they
would continue their old protectorate
relationship with Spain we got bogged
down into that rebellion for 14 years
that's followed by the Northwest Indian
War at 10 years the Iraq war at 8.8
revolutionary war at a point for Vietnam
and 8.1 the Second Seminole War at 6.7
the first Barbary war at 4.1 the Civil
War at four and world war ii at 3.7 it's
interesting to note that a full forty
percent of those wars possibly more if
you count the war against isis
separately
a full 40 percent of the longest wars in
US history
have been defending against Muslim
forces something that isn't talked about
very much and it's a strange quirk of US
history
now that is by no means a list of the
deadliest wars in US history that list
goes Civil War World War 2 World War 1
Vietnam Korea the revolution 1812
Mexican American War Iraq and
Afghanistan combined as one conflict in
the philippine-american war so what do
we do about the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan part of the reason we
haven't had a parade is that they've
been so politicized by the left since
the beginning and we might keep troops
in Afghanistan for decades we might not
pull all of them out right away so can
we honor the veterans who signed up to
protect our freedom after the worst
terrorist attack on American soil
on September 11 2001 we have parades and
demonstrations for a lot of other things
I'll just refresh your memory of the
last year
[ __ ] hats gay pride Superbowl here a
lot of parades actually that Super Bowl
parade I think it's just when they
torched Philadelphia but that's a
separate demonstration is it really so
awful to celebrate and thank our troops
reports indicate the president Trump is
considering hosting the parade on
Memorial Day or the 4th of July or
Veterans Day not on a random Tuesday not
just when on his birthday or something
like that there if all of the reports
say he's got those dates picked out for
the parade of the three Veterans Day
seems like the best time to me that's a
time when we're already honoring the
troops fourth of July celebrates the
fanning of our country Veterans Day
seems like the right way to do it if
it's done right not only will it not be
an unprecedented threat to the Republic
or whatever they're saying it is it will
be admirable and long overdue
comfortable Americans have had the
privilege of keeping war out of their
minds for the most part since 9/11
because of the brave men and women who
answered the call of duty and defended
our freedom overseas a parade through
the streets of Washington DC to honor
them if done right could go a long way
toward focusing Americans attention on
just what our country has been doing in
Iraq and Afghanistan and to remind us
that our freedom doesn't come free but
instead has been purchased at a high
cost that we are so privileged in this
country that most of the time we don't
even have to notice that cost and Donald
Trump in suggesting this military parade
which is
in well keeping with us tradition seems
to be provoking the left into attacking
our military like lunatics it's a it's a
really bad look for them Donald Trump is
very good at at putting his adversaries
into a corner and making them defend the
indefensible making their true colors
shine through it looks like what's
happening here
fine by me seems like a lot of good
things are being accomplished in it okay
we've got to get to our panel we have a
lovely panel today it's it's an old
ladies panel it's much more beautiful
than we usually have we have Jacob we
pluck him off the sidewalks or something
you know all ladies panel today of
Arielle Davidson and Alicia crass but
first before we can get to them I have
got I've got to talk about man things
we've got this lady panel actually I
guess they make products for women too
but I use this every morning
it is Dollar Shave Club you hear me talk
about it a lot I use it all the time
it's the best razor I've ever used and I
don't skimp on razors I get nice razors
and usually as gifts or something and I
never go to the pharmacy I never try to
replace the blades I don't want to do
that I am a millennial I do not want to
move I want to move the least amount
that I possibly can I don't want to get
ripped off I want things to be mailed to
me and make it easy Dollar Shave Club
does just that so you hear me talk about
my razor it's it's the best razor I've
ever used what's really nice too is that
dr. Carver's shaved butter I don't use
that crazy shaving like the puffy stuff
you put on your face I don't use shave
gel because I have some self-respect on
my own but then on my face the shave
butter is really really nice I am never
gonna give up my membership in fact I'm
adding even more DSC products to my
daily routine so Dollar Shave Club makes
products for your hair face skin shower
everything you need and it's all their
own original stuff they use only the
finest premium ingredients they deliver
it to you just like they do their razors
no more trips to the store no more you
know you're looking for the Isle of
photos there are the razors down this
aisle and you go down the wrong aisle if
you're a man you start feeling very
weird about that and you looked at
anyone see me as this I feel icky being
here
don't do that don't come on save
yourself the hassle I use Dollar Shave
Club for almost everything they have
razors and body cleanser hair gel they
even have this is a little difficult to
talk about on the show you know and
you're up they're very they're clean
they have this product called a bidet
it's an invention that they use
Americans don't really use it gets you
it makes you feel a little fresh at
times when you might not be feeling the
freshest helps you clean places on your
body where the Sun don't shine
well Dollar Shave Club has lovely wipes
to cleanse that derriere of yours and it
has you covered head to toe so now is a
great time to give Dollar Shave Club a
try you get your first month of their
best razor along with travel size but
versions of shave butter body cleanser
and yes even that derriere cleanser for
just 5 dollars this is basically free
you would be a fool not to do it get it
right now it's just the razor is so good
all of the products are really good
after that replacement cartridge is
shipped for just a few bucks a month you
never have to worry about it it is the
DSC starter set get yours for just $5
exclusively dollarshaveclub.com slash co
f f/a co v fe fe that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash coffe a faint
Marshall what is it dollarshaveclub.com
slash / FF a that's what it is
alright let's get to this panel Oh
Marshall you monster I'm are you kidding
me I have to sign off we didn't get to
talk about the parades
you you are a sick sadist that your head
is so awful yeah well don't blame me
guys blame Marshall we have got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube I
already I think I already said goodbye
to YouTube when they started censoring
all of my videos a few weeks ago and
cutting off our live streams that's a
separate point at this point by the way
basically all of my episodes are being
censored on YouTube I did that interview
with father Mike Schmidt's the other day
about what is marriage and all that
apparently suggesting that the
definition of marriage from the dawn of
time until about five and a half minutes
ago suggesting that that might not have
been totally mistaken that is enough to
get you censored on YouTube and that
they're killing us on this so I guess
I'm probably not seeing you on YouTube
I'm probably seeing you on Facebook if
you're they're gonna tell you why you're
calm right now what will you get
yeah that's $10 a month $100 for an
annual membership get the annual
membership you'll see why you get me the
intercalated show the ben shapiro show
no ads on the website the conversation
coming up with me
coming up around Valentine's Day baby it
is going Alicia's gonna be hosting it
I'm gonna give you all my love advice
the love doctor will be in the house and
I can promise you it will give you
either romantic bliss or have you
shunned and thrown out a window or
something so you get all that but who
cares which you really get is this once
those tanks start rolling once those
tanks are rolling down Pennsylvania
Avenue they I hope they can float
because they are gonna be so many
leftist tears pouring out throughout our
nation's capital you need this leftist
tears tumbler we better stop we better
send a lot of these down to Washington
DC or else we could have a national
disaster on our hands the leftist here's
temporal ER the only vessel that is FDA
NSA FBI IMF approved to store your
radioactive leftist tears always salty
and delicious whether they be hot or
cold go to daily wire.com right now
we'll be right back
and you took Ariel away from me Marshall
also took Ariel away from me but that's
fine that means that I get Alicia all to
myself today I thought I was gonna have
to wait until the conversation but I get
Alicia all to myself Alicia thank you
for being here
of course Thanks so the first thing I
need your thoughts what do you think
about this parade I gotta say reading
the report
at first I was kind of like yeah and
then I really came to the conclusion
that you did I'm a child of the 80s and
I remember proper and like marching
after Operation Desert Storm
as you mentioned I also remember me
reading the generals biography and I
think it's the first time I'd asked my
mom what the F word was because there
was lots of those most military books my
generals
I remember reading for scums a biography
but I think that I think that really
these things exist I mean I have friends
that were recently at the Rose Bowl you
have flyovers you know the national
anthem you've the beautiful flag
displays on the field these things
already kind of exist so I have mixed
feelings on it I think that it is okay
to show support of the military I think
that it is important to especially after
the horrible way that our Vietnam
veterans were treated coming home from
Vietnam to continue to show past present
and military members and service men and
women our appreciation for them but I
think that you know as a trump sometimes
skeptic I also get how some people
jumped to the oh god he's Mussolini he's
Mussolini
he's Mussolini who's kim jeong-hoon it
just adds fodder to like the the
argument that he is this evil dictator
Donald and and I think that he needs to
be very careful not to play into this
and I have to say I'm a fan of Sarah
Huckabee Sanders but today I listened to
the press conference that she did live
and her answers to this were very vague
and very unclear and I think that they
just need to come out swinging with
their talking points of this is what the
president meant this is who it came from
this is the purpose for it and we're
looking into options but when they don't
answer direct questions it feeds into
the negative narrative that's right and
I think there is a little bit here of
Chesterton's the thought that stops
thought I think a lot of people that the
society is so postmodern we've
questioned
so much of even our own institutions
even the premises of our government of
our society that now in the fashionable
elites circles military services taboo
it so it's so not nice those men they
shoot guns sometimes they shoot them at
brown people that's what let's forget
about that we don't we can't acknowledge
that but of course the military of the
guys who defend our freedom there are a
lot of people who don't like our freedom
and our government and they want to
attack us and it is important I think to
remember especially in an era where
something like 1% of the country has
ever served in the military 1 2 3 % that
we remind ourselves that the reason that
we can have lovely political debates and
make art and movies and write books and
in my case not write books like books
yeah write blank books and have a nice
life is because there are rough men out
there who were shooting guns on our
behalf and keeping the bad guys away
that that's absolutely right they're
gonna say it's fascism but they say
everything with Trump is fascism they
say that deregulation is fascism I don't
know how they got to that
okay so again variations on a theme
there were new FBI texts that are
exposing these are unbelievable because
it gets to Barack Obama in typical Trump
fashion the president tweeted quote new
FBI texts are bombshells it all caps of
course the new texts show FBI agent
Peter struck I pronounce extrinsic
because it's like 75 consonants and no
syllables telling fellow agent Lisa
Paige that FBI director James Comey
wanted them to prepare an update on
investigations because quote POTUS wants
to know everything we're doing that's
the same POTUS you'll remember who said
on national television that he would
never participate in or politicize any
agency investigation here's Barack Obama
I do not talk to the Attorney General
about pending investigations I do not
talk to FBI directors about pending
investigations they we have a strict
line and always have maintained it for
those presidents just a button this up I
guarantee it you I guarantee that there
is no political influence in any
investigation conducted by the Justice
Department or the FBI
not just in this case but in any case
and she will all stop period and she
will be treated no Deron seed full stop
nobody gets treated differently when it
comes to the Justice Department because
nobody is above the law even if she ends
up as the Democratic how many time do I
have to say Chris guarantee I guarantee
you how many times strive to say it how
many times . . barack obama is so good
at looking like the president and
looking like he's telling the truth and
he's so good at playing except he isn't
he's this corrosive corrupt awful figure
who really did significant harm to the
country and to the government lying to
your face and saying i am putting all my
credibility on the line . . alicia is
this proof positive that barack obama
may have been lying not may have other
things that he misled and blatantly lied
about to the american people
iran deal anyone it in the bible but we
would call this a crock of crap because
you can't you know that's the closest to
a curse where it is i can get this
language we ever have on this show and i
think that is a crock of crap and good
for chris wallace there i think of it if
it had been a more friendly interview we
wouldn't have that soundbite all these
years later and in addition to this this
this text messages between these FBI
lovers by the way saying hey the
director wants us to keep him apprised
of what's happening so he can tell the
commander in chief the President of the
United States what's up means 1 the
obama administration knew in addition to
that they probably were they aware of
the fusion gps thing were they aware of
this dossier were way they were-- of how
the FISA warrant was obtained i think
any reporter worth their grain of salt
who gets an opportunity to talk to
Barack and Michelle Obama even though
they've left the White House should
definitely bring that up and loose lips
sink ships these are just the loose text
messages that we happen to see about
this that they happen to write down very
stupidly I mean you should never send a
text or an email that you're not
comfortable having on the cover of the
New York Times but they just let these
ones go what what aren't we see what
what was going to
there has to be other communications and
there has to be emails and I want to see
this the broad brush of the timeline of
what was happening with the white house
what was happening during the Clinton
and Trump campaigns and what was
happening during the investigation at
this time
with these now memos and emails and text
messages and everything that we're going
to see as they're opened up to the
American public so we now see the Barack
Obama himself all the way up to the
president was inserting himself into
what should have been independent agency
investigations during the 2016 campaign
investigations that pertained to Hillary
Clinton we have a lot of evidence that
the initial Russia investigation was
triggered by Democrat money by Democrat
operatives some with ties to the
Clintons does all of this taken together
all of this rancid stench from Barack
Obama's politicized agencies does it
undermine the mulher investigation I
think unfortunately it does and I think
that you know obviously and I think that
the United States should take very
seriously and I think that Trump
shouldn't take it so personally that
there's this investigation into Russia's
meddling and there are two separate
things
it's did Russia metal in the
investigation and I'm sorry in the
election probably but that doesn't mean
that they necessarily meddled in it for
the purpose of Trump winning they just
did it because they spy on everybody and
everything they've been doing it forever
Russians have been screwing us for a
long time that is a very serious problem
that our securities and our departments
and all of the bureaucracy of government
should be make sure you know people
cannot meddle in our elections but I
think that it also does undermine the
separate investigation of you know is
Trump involved with Russia and is he
really a liaison to Vladimir Putin and
all these ranchers in Canada is this
mentoring candidate excetera I will
flatly say though that Carter Paige I
mean there's some shady stuff there
whether or not Donald Trump knew about
it I'm gonna err on the side of no he
didn't and maybe once they found out
that's why he left the campaign or maybe
because he's just a shady McShane derson
they had him kicked out of the campaign
even before they knew too many of his
involvement and stuff with the Kremlin
but I think that unfortunately for
Hillary Clinton for the Democrats going
forward specifically in 2018 midterms in
2020 when you know that this is what
they wanted to take and run with it
President Trump it's gonna look as if
the molar investigation is jeopardized
by all of this stuff that's happening
within the FBI and the DOJ absolutely
it's inevitable even if Muller really is
this man of integrity even the struck
the most upstanding citizen in the room
it just looks awful we know it has
association with all of this Democrat
hacker it's really no good I sort of
feel for the guy but they they have to
wrap this up it's just and who knows but
some people are saying Donald Trump has
to release everything you don't have to
release everything he should he should
absolutely not release everything he
should hold all of his leverage as long
as he can drip drip drip and let Hillary
Clinton and Barack Obama sweat and on
that point trey Gowdy has now all but
admitted that the source of information
passed a Hillary State Department to be
passed to dossier author Christopher
steel to be passed back to Barack
Obama's FBI was Clinton hatch a man Sid
Blumenthal that means the entire Russia
collusion investigation circus it could
have been funded it could have been a
charade funded orchestrated and executed
by Clinton cronies to undermine Trump's
campaign Alicia if gaudi's suggestion is
true does the FBI investigation into
Trump Russia collusion blah blah blah do
any of these have credibility do some of
them have credibility but not all of
them how do we parse this it's so
confusing that my head is in this every
day and sometimes I need to think okay
wait no we're talking about this one
we're not talking about this one
oh gosh all the names all of the details
all of the warrants all of the drama I
mean even all of the congressmen
involved at this point you have get
trade Goudy that's come out and said
this but then you also have Nunez that
wrote the the GOP you know memo about
this memo gate of what what was said and
how the dossier was used to obtain the
FISA warrant etc and let's just say when
it comes to congressmen I think that I'm
really inclined to believe a trey Gowdy
/ a Devin Nunez I think that Gowdy has a
history of a prosecutor he is very good
when it comes to QA he's he's shown that
over and over again I'm so sad he's not
running for re-election and so when
Gowdy implies that Sidney Blumenthal who
is known as you mentioned to be Hillary
Clinton's hatchet man even after by the
way the Obama administration and
President Obama specifically told her
when she was at the Department of State
that they didn't want her working with
good old
she went around the Obama
administration's back and kept doing it
of course I believe this to be true
mainly because it's coming from trade at
Goudy but also because it totally fits
into the timetable image narrative and
the personality traits of the Clintons
yep do you think people will go to jail
for this or are they just all gonna get
off clean like the Clintons always seem
to do I think the latter unfortunately
it seems as if anybody with the name and
money whether it's in politics or
Hollywood tends to get away with things
that you and I never could or would that
is true sad sad to quote a great man
finally the most important story of the
day
Canada's ken-doll prime minister Justin
Trudeau he now wants to change the word
mankind to people kind to make it less
sexist here is Prime Minister kendall
maternal love is the love that's going
to change the future of mankind so we'd
like you to look we would like to say
people kind not necessarily mankind so
just to clarify for Prime Minister
Kendall and anyone in the audience who
has never looked at an Oxford English
Dictionary the word man can be gender
neutral it is a gender-neutral word in
the Bible it is clearly written in the
beginning God created man both male and
female he created them created man both
male and female how dare you use the
Bible my patriotic a book written by a
big Jewish man in the sky outrageous
outrageous by the way I'm because I'm
such a political nerd if I ever which I
never will
sorry mom I never will run for office I
would want and be a representative on
the federal level I would want to be
called Congressman Krause because turns
out like for that very reason that you
mentioned male can man can be male or
female and in Robert's Rules of Order
it's supposed to be them the man this
congresswoman stuff is crap every single
time I see it this is the most sensible
thing that's been said on my show all
day maybe all year this is so it's so
Elementary except we don't study
anything nobody studies grammar or
language nor anything that was written
more than three seconds ago and not
texted is political correctness making
us all
stupid or is this is this a failure of
education and how do you fix it of
course it's a failure of Education I
mean I just wrench in Robert's Rules of
Order and it's educated as an awesome as
you're the majority of your audience is
I guarantee you they haven't had it oh
my god they're all of my audience lives
in the 19th century and puffs on pipes
and cigars
you are right most people have no idea
what Robert's rusev or order is yeah
they don't understand how the three
branches of government work and it's the
reason everybody freaked out after you
know Donald Trump actually became
president they don't understand the
importance of those branches of states
rights of the basics you know principles
of the Constitution or you know basic
grammar which listen I am no grammar
queen I'm awful at it been often
subtweet Smee and corrects my grammar
within my hundred forty or 280 character
tweets that's fine I get it hashtag
homeschooled but there are basic things
that have not been taught in in our
schools for generations and now it's
going to continue to get worse because
they're more worried about hay saying Z
versus he so they don't offend you know
less than 1% percent of the student body
it is also a crime in some ways it's a
it's an epidemic that's growing because
more people are writing more frequently
now we're all texting constantly rather
than writing a letter or two per day or
dictating or something so it's just
infecting all of the culture this
terrible grammar and writing and abusive
language which is political correctness
it's an abusive language my question
with Trudeau I've often said that if
Trudeau did not exist we would have to
invent him his is Justin Trudeau Prime
Minister Kendall is he trolling us he's
you know when he goes down the little
short-shorts waving the gay flag easy a
cynical politician or is he really the
doe-eyed dumb-dumb that he appears no
he's definitely like a mix I don't know
that he's yes the answer is yes but I
think what you asked osya cynical
politician errs he is delighted as he
appears I think it's a mix of both I
think that the doe-eyed miss is
potentially part of his cynicism and he
projects that because he knows that it
helps his socialist you know Canada
voters it helps him not the whole of the
country of Canada by the way there's
lots of really great Canadian
conservatives and I know that they watch
religiously and all these podcasts over
here at the Daily wire so you know I
really like y'all's maple syrup
that's true the greatest living stand-up
comedian Norm Macdonald is very Canadian
there you go there's lots of amazing
comics but like please keep Trudeau
don't let that seep into the United
States as Ben likes to call him the
better-looking Bernie Sanders y'all can
keep him I hope you vote him out because
you deserve better
absolutely right I just I only want him
to exist from afar magazine covers
waving the flags and the little short
despots when he opens his mouth with the
trouble exactly we want to be able to
point and laugh you don't want to have
to take responsibility for it absolutely
right okay well that's it I guess if I
want to have any political success I got
to start working and become a big hunk
like him if we're gonna fight this just
wait for it people man has thinner legs
than I do
that is true we've got the conversation
coming up more sweetly you will see soon
for yourself you're gonna you're in for
a treat we did the early shoot a couple
days ago and it's a feast for the eyes
you're gonna we're gonna have some of
the audience just spooning out their
minds I like blinding themselves okay
that's a show Alicia thank you for being
here very illuminating that's it
that is all of it I hope I hope that you
can now spread a little bit of knowledge
to these historically ignorant lefties
who tell you it's unprecedented and kill
make sure you collect those leftist
tears maybe send me a nice vintage you
know I collect them too
that's our show on Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show tune in
tomorrow we'll do it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy Borah senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex zingaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina herons
makeup is by Joshua Avera the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for word
publishing 2018